le premier jour de collecte a plutôt
bien démarré pour les bénévoles de la
banque alimentaire
pour olivier qui participent à
l'opération depuis de nombreuses années
les clients se montre heureux même plus
réceptif à leurs sollicitations
depuis le mouvement des gilet jaune et
j'en arrive avec plus de le sourire avec
un peu plus de chaleur parce que je
pense qu'effectivement avoir conservé un
petit peu de déversoir les gens étaient
un peu mécontent il y avait un peu de la
grogne
ils savaient pas qu'ils ont appris qu il
le dira chacun a ses difficultés ses
difficultés sociales professionnelles et
je pense que là effectivement de pouvoir
s'exprimer peut-être que d'autres
personnes se sont exprimées à leur place
les jets les journaux ça m'a servi de
soupape pour ces personnes-là une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation des
gilet jaune est attendu pour ce week end
avec le risque de voir la collecte
compromise par le blocage des entrées
aux grandes surfaces
fabian lui pourtant soutien des gilet
jaune conteste ce mode d'action je suis
pas pour les blocages
abrupt comme ça ni ni pour des extrêmes
je pense que ça peut se passer en bon
enfant comme on voit au niveau des
émissions
et il n'y a pas de raison de radicaliser
le mouvement à la banque alimentaire du
loiret on a préféré anticiper les
éventuels blocages des routes en
communiquant auprès des gilet jaune
je suis à peu près certaine que les chez
les jaunes vont tout à fait comprendre
qu'on s'inscrit dans une grande
opération de solidarité qu'ils vont y
participer qui seront même des acteurs
puisqu'on a eu l'occasion de leur donner
des flyers à suite à leur demande
on part du principe qu'ils vont laisser
passer les camions de la banque
alimentaire qui vont circuler mais aussi
la clientèle qui va accéder aux
différents points de collecte sont les
grandes les grandes surfaces et les
moyennes surfaces
les dons des consommateurs durant ces
trois jours ils ont permis l'an dernier
de récolter 95 tonnes de denrées
alimentaires sur le loiret bonsoir
flavien texier justement on va plus loin
avec vous sur cette antenne de la banque
alimentaire du loiret
l'année dernière elle a aidé 18000
personnes oui bonsoir fais à 18000
personnes dans le loiret et bien cela
représente environ 7000 foyers
bénéficiaires à l'échelle de ce
département et pour venir en aide à
toutes ces personnes la banque
alimentaire récupère toute l'année vous
le savez de la nourriture en provenance
principalement des grandes surfaces
rien que l'an passé dans le loiret 1300
tonnes de denrées ont été récoltés et
sur ses 1300 tonnes 95 tonnes ont été
récupérées durant le fameux week-end de
la grande collecte les marchandises sont
ensuite stockés on l'a vu dans le
reportage dans les entrepôts de la
banque alimentaire avant d'être
distribuée au ccas les centres communaux
d'action sociale mais également des
associations caritatives comme par
exemple les restos du coeur dans le
loiret une centaine de crs et
d'associations sont ainsi sollicité
faiza pour aider justement les personnes
en grande difficulté parole pour que ça
fonctionne pour que cette activité
puisse perdurer
combien de personnes travaillent au
quotidien pour cette antenne du loret et
bien pour faire fonctionner la banque
alimentaire du loiret faiza on compte
six salariés et environ une cinquantaine
de bénévoles ils sont répartis sur les
villes d'orléans et de montargis un tout
dernier chiffre maintenant qui illustre
parfaitement la précarité croissante
l'an passé la banque alimentaire de
l'ain
à distribuer environ 720 mille repas
c'est quasiment 45 % de hausse en trois
ans merci à vous flavien texier